okay members uh and ladies and gentlemen
good evening and welcome to tonight's
planning committee meeting my name's
cancer peter richards and i will be
chairing tonight's meeting um some
housekeeping to start with we're not
expecting there to be any uh fire alarms
but if there is one please do follow us
out to the car park next to windmill and
we can make sure that everyone has got
out safely mobile phones if you would
turn them off that would be helpful i'm
perfectly happy to use them provided
they don't distract uh and deter from
the flow of the meeting but please at
the minimum please can you put them on
silent um so we don't have any
distractions
uh this meeting is uh a meeting in
public it is not a public meeting so
only those people that have registered
to speak will be allowed to speak um at
the appropriate time i will call you
forward sit in the chair in the middle
if you could please keep your mask on
until you are sat down
and once you're finished uh please stay
seated for questions and then uh when
you are leaving the seat if you could
please use the uh wipes to give the desk
a quick wipe and the microphone a quick
wipe and also sanitize your hands
there's a bin just to the left hand side
as you're sat there to put those in that
would be great
okay let's do some introductions uh
first of all so uh to my far right we
have sophie jarrett who is our community
services representative to my immediate
right we have ross chambers who is our
solicitor
and in no particular order we have our
planners who are joe brooke aaron
weatherstone and stuart flaherty uh we
have joining us on uh online so on the
big screens we have paul harris and to
my immediate left we have david
jefferies who is our planning manager
david i think you have us something
you'd like to say for us thank you chair
my role is to provide impartial advice
and to assist members in their decision
taking thank you marvelous thank you
very much okay let's move into the
agenda proper so first of all apologies
for absence do we have any apologies
please thank you chairman we have
apologies from councillors crump and
edin tonight
marvelous thank you very much and
disclosures of interest members um there
are two that i'm going to kick us off
with if i may uh on application 2102 854
out that land north of collingham lane
in longington i've certainly received
various emails and correspondence in
relation to that i believe it's been
copped into all of you i'm seeing lots
of nods so we'll do a blanket disclosure
on that one um and also um
uh i
i'm trying to remember which one it was
now
i think it's pitton hill cottages
21-0-2-3-0-2
f-u-l again a couple of emails that i've
had on that one uh from parish councils
and representatives so um i'm seeing
lots of nods i'm assuming you've all
received the same yep so we'll do a
blanket for that one any other
disclosures we want to make cancer adam
first
uh thank you chairman um just say that
i'm the ward member forum
the first application
and so i won't be
staying on the committee for that
particular one
okay marvelous cancer mills
oh gosh thank you for the chairman i'm
on item five on the agenda uh the
stables at wellington lane i'm actually
the county councillor for that uh area
and on um
item six on the agenda for pint hill
cottages i am the award member but i
won't be voting and i'll step back from
the um
from the desk when uh debating thank you
are we uh so you stepping back on both
of those so the stables in wellington
lane and um pertinent hill cottages or
just one of them just the one just for
putting it just a bit in your culture
and you'll remain for the stables in
wilmington okay thank you very much uh
members any other disclosures at this
stage
no in that case minutes is everyone
happy with the minutes as they're
presented
uh if i could just have quick nods yes
everyone's all good thumbs up i'll sign
those after okay we are going to do a
slight uh rejig of the running order um
you'll note in your update sheet
uh item uh number four on our list is
2102854
outland at collingham lane in long
itchington we have had an update it um
there is an updated uh recommendation
which is to defer
uh
for the details laid out in that update
sheet um could i i think we should take
that now so if i could have a proposal
to defer
for the reasons to set out councillor
kendall seconded by uh councillor mills
a quick show of hands please that are an
agreement obviously cancer adam can't
vote on this one
i believe that to be unanimous so uh we
will be deferring that or have deferred
that item um and the
uh we will be bringing forward uh
application
uh sorry item number seven which is
application twenty one zero three three
zero eight very that is orchard
nurseries uh in welfare on avon uh in
line with the constitution we have no
registered uh parish council or
um
uh councillor um and the uh the
applicants have uh removed their
registration to speak so we have no
speakers at all now uh so we will be
delegating that could i have a proposal
to delegate that council adam seconded
uh councillor jennings please um and a
show of hands please for those in favor
that is unanimous okay marvelous so uh
our first item then this evening will be
application reference 21 0 1 4 2 3 ful
the stables in warmington and our
presenting officers aaron wilson erin
over to you
thank you simon
the application site lies to the east of
warmington which is identified as an all
of the settlement within the council's
adopted core strategy and identified by
the black dot on this plan just here
this slide shows the application site
outlined in red the site lies within the
iso hill special landscape area and is
crossed by public right of way sm 160
which you can see here there's a green
dash line
to the south of the application site
sorry is that better
okay
to the south of the application cyclist
wilmington conservation area which is
shown just here with a pink line
and a grade two listed building which is
shown just here
in red
this is the closest neighboring property
to the site
the site lies outside of the cotswolds
area of outstanding natural beauty
however land to the south of molington
lane just south of this lane here falls
within this designation site also falls
within 500 metres of ancient woodlands
existing access from wellington lanes
proposed to be retained just here
so the use of the site lies in existing
sewage works just here and to the south
of garage
site comprises of a parcel of land with
planning permission for egyptian
traveler site with a personal permission
planning permission is sought to
encompass the land associated with the
most recent permission
two eight six nine full
the changes proposed as part of this
application include a substitution of a
touring caravan for a new mobile static
home an addition of a further family who
have links to the sites to the current
occupants
if granted this will result in four
mobile homes on the land one touring
caravan the erection of one amenity
building for four families and their
resident dependents and associated works
this slide shows an aerial image of the
area with the approximate location of
the site outlined in red just here
existing caravans on the land are
visible in this image along with the
access to the bollington lane to the
south
the wider parcel of land comprises of
four areas the two to the north here and
here are used for the sighting of
caravans there's then an open parcel of
land shown just here which is crossed by
public right of way sm 160 in this
location just here
and closest to the road planning
permission was granted four stables in
2006. the wide parcel of land is
screened by existing vegetation all
sides here to the north to the east and
to the south
the landscape within the immediate area
of the site is relatively flat with open
fields visible to the north to the east
and to the west of the application site
warmington is visible just here on the
slide
this slideshow post application site
outlined in red on the right hand side
of this slide and the red line
associated with the most recent planning
permission on the site on the left
this slide shows proposed site plan you
can see on the right hand side of the
slide the main difference is changing a
touring pitch which is here to a new
mobile static home and changes to the
landscaping the existing amenity
building which was previously approved
is proposed in the same location just
here
this slide has proposed floor plans and
elevations of the amenities building
which is simply in design with a pitched
roof the building will measure
approximately 2.7 meters to the eaves
and 4.4 meters to the ridge which is
proposed to be finished in timber
boarding under tile roof
this slider is a photograph taken from
the access road looking in a southern
direction towards wellington lane which
you can see just here
to the right of the image you can see
the extent of the public right of way
that crosses the site through to the
countryside beyond and the land where
planning permission was granted for the
stable building closest to molington
lane
this slide shows two photographs taken
within the parcel of land closest to
wellington lane looking back towards the
application site you can see the parcel
plan where the footpath crosses with the
caravans to the rear of this image and
the image to the right you can see the
access road from molington lane which is
the right of this photograph leading
into the application site
this slide shows a photograph of the
southern part of the application site
looking west from the access road
existing caravans on the land
and this photograph has taken a look at
the northern portion of the application
site looking in a north western
direction you can see just here on the
plan
this slider is a photograph taken from
public right of way sm-160 looking west
towards the application site
see the existing gas work see which
treatment works just here and the
application site behind
this photograph was taken from public
right-of-way sm-160 looking east towards
the application site and the arrow shows
the approximate location of the site
just here
this final slide shows a photograph
taken from wellington lane from within
the conservation area boundary your plot
location of the site is just where the
arrow is shown you can see the grey two
listed building located just to the
right of this image there are a number
of updates for this application which
have been circulated on the update sheet
including two additional notes it is
recommended that planning permission be
granted subject to conditions and notes
for the reasons outlined in the officer
report thank you
erin thank you very much we will call
ford asks first speaker on this item who
is councillor mark burstall chairman of
warmington and oscar parish council
good evening and welcome
and once you're settled you'll have
three minutes
um you'll press if you press the button
in the middle i don't know if you've
used this before if you press the button
in the middle it'll turn red and you'll
be able to start speaking you'll have
three minutes if you stay seated for
questions afterwards otherwise whenever
you're ready you're free to start
good evening
one important fact stands out in this
application
this is an attempt to increase the
number of permanent traveler pitches on
the site by one that may not sound very
much but in reality it's a 33 increase
in the number of static caravans
once again the applicant has seen fit to
act first and then make a retrospective
application once found out
the site has a significant planning
history with the council's decisions
being regularly appealed
in each case the planning inspector has
seen fit to impose a strict limit on the
number of stats static caravans that
should be allowed
and they have set out very good reasons
why such limits should be imposed
i urge you to take these into
consideration
the applicant remains in breach of some
of the conditions previously imposed
the planning statement which accompanies
the application form
is so heavily redacted
that it is meaningless and provides no
basis for considering the merits of the
application
there are a number of core strategy
policies which must be taken into
account
cs8 the site is immediately adjacent to
the warmington conservation area and to
a listed building
cs11 the site is adjacent to the
cotswold aonb
and as such should be protected
it appears that the cotswold
conservation board were not consulted on
this application
their views are important
the application site lies within the
designated special landscape area known
as the ironstone hills fringe
the purpose of the special landscape
area designation is to protect enhance
and facilitate better management of the
best of the area's landscapes outside
the cotswold aonb
cs21 covers gypsies and travelers and
travelling show people and i refer you
in particular to sections 2 3 and 11.
also cs21 7 location
the nearest local service village is
benny compton which is almost twice as
far as the two miles specified in
government guidance
no public transport goes there
cs 2112 requires arrangements to be put
in place to ensure the proper management
of the site
to seek to ensure community cohesion
between the settled and traveler
communities
sadly the opposite is true
there is already a great deal of tension
between the settled local community and
the travelers
many local people have told me they
wanted to object to this application
but felt unable to do so because of a
perceived threat to them and their
families
if you decide to grant this application
then something must be done to resolve
this issue
were this anything other than a
traveller site i have no doubt that the
planning department would view it rather
differently
it may be that they would welcome the
additional pitch because of the
difficulty that stratfor has in meeting
its target
but the need for pitches should not be
exaggerated
in nearby farnborough there are
insufficient travelers to take up the
available pictures
i ask you to reject this application
on the basis that it conflicts with so
many core strategy clauses
and that it represents over development
of the site
thank you
that's versatile thank you very much for
that members do we have any questions
for our parish councillor councilman
mills
thanks chairman um mark did you
my mission did you say that it was
limited to the number of caravans on
there
uh yes the previous planning inspectors
have put a limit of three
right permanent caravans okay
and this application is seeking to
exchange a mobile caravan or a static
paradigm
right okay that increases the number of
pictures by one
got that thank you
thank you
council curses
thank you um
thank you very much for that
presentation um you mentioned um briefly
mark um
that the applicant is in breach of
previous conditions but you didn't give
any further detail could you give some
more detail on that please
if you have them
to hand i'm concerned that any breaches
would be
more relevant
directed towards our um
at the appropriate teams within the
district council it's not for us to
decide on those uh and unless there's
clear evidence that's been presented
which it hasn't been to date then we
probably shouldn't be
taking that into our consideration
unless you have any other questions i'm
not inclined to agree chair but thank
you
counselor adam
thanks um just in
regard to availability of alternative
sites she mentioned that there was
somewhere else nearby
that had availability where was that
sorry
okay any other questions for our parish
councillor
no in that case council vessel thank you
very much for your time contribution
this evening and thank you for preparing
to clean the desk for us
and while you do that i will just let
everyone know that our next speaker will
be councillor fielding cancer fielding
if you stay seated until council bursal
has
uh left his seat and then when you're
ready you can come forward
thank you
now cancer fielding as you know you'll
have five minutes once you've plugged
yourself in and got yourself settled uh
whenever you're ready you may begin
it just makes all the difference to
hearing what's being said
particularly when i'm sitting behind you
all
um before i start
i'd like to make clear that these
comments based purely on planning
matters i respect the needs of the
planning
of the planning uh traveling community
castlefield do you want to take your
mask off so we might be able to hear you
thanks
i have paused your time
hearing aids come out
um
i respect the needs of the traveling
community
and i'm not against helping them to find
suitable sites
i have joined my time on the planning
committee found a retrospective planning
application
goes against the spirit
of the sdc's core strategy
this application is one of many that
could be classified as creeping
development
in in the documentation
you have before you concerning the
application you will see that there has
been a number of planning applications
for retrospective development however
these have been granted on appeal
you will note
on page 42
last paragraph the applicant is
has still not dealt with the conditions
that were set out in the planning
inspectors report of 2016.
landscaping
being the main failure join
together with other conditions
i do not understand why the officer is
prepared to grant this application when
applicant has not completed these works
the officers refers to other conditions
john sorry i've paused your time again
um
it seems your microphone is no longer on
or was not your microphone doesn't
appear to be on
um whilst i have heard everything is it
is it on now yeah it's been all the time
okay um you
i i we i have heard everything i've just
been if you want me to play it again no
absolutely not um if you can bring the
microphone somewhere closer to you so we
fair enough
um if you just make sure your microphone
is close enough to you so we can we can
hear that'll be great whenever you're
ready you can continue i have paused
your time well stop on for page 42 the
last paragraph the applicant has still
not dealt with the conditions
that were set up by the planning
inspector the report of 2016.
landscaping being the main failure other
than together with other conditions i do
not understand why the officer is
prepared to grant this application when
the applicant has not completed these
works
the officer refers to conditions she
will impose
council councillor burstler has set out
the course strategy that are relevant to
this case however 21 cs21 part 11 and 12
must be adhered to
they are important
my main concern is that will the
conditions that sdc and the inspector
imposed be carried out
and therefore
are we going to be granting permission
with conditions which are then going to
be ignored
chess philly thank you very much members
do we have any questions for cancer
filming please
no
fabulous counseling thank you very much
your time contribution
uh while cancer feeling is getting
themselves uh taken away could you if
you could please please give the desk a
white cancer feeling that would be great
thank you very much while he's doing
that we shall move into our next phase
which is um questions or points of
application to our offices i've got a
few listed but i'll open up to the
committee first to see if anyone wants
to dive in and ask anything
council jennings
as it's been raised previous conditions
haven't been haven't been met could you
get a bit of clarification on that
please
so as part of this application we're
considering it as a new application and
we have recommended conditions including
landscaping to come in as part of this
scheme that we're looking at um and
those all meet the tests so we're happy
that we get an updated landscape and
scheme in relation to the the changes
that propose as part of this development
if i may follow on from that we've
obviously heard that there are breaches
uh or so or alleged breaches
am i right and i think this is probably
more uh directed to our solicitor am i
right and thinking that is a question
for us
our enforcement team and if there are
continued breaches or non-compliance
with conditions that would go through
our enforcement team it is not for this
committee to decide upon
correct
that was simple you very much um anyone
else have any other questions before i
dive through a couple of others
counselor adam
thank you um just one of the things that
the parish councillor raised which i
asked on um the availability of
alternatives do you want to take your
mask off please
forget
yeah um the availability of um
alternative sites i noticed in your
report you've referenced um
[Music]
the warwickshire county council owned
sites but um he referenced one farmer
and cherwell um do you have any
information on that and the availability
of alternatives so when we look at these
applications we consider what what
provision we've got within the district
and paslo is the site we've got 30
pictures but it's full so when we're
looking at availability i'm not aware of
any other sites these might be private
sites but in terms of in the local
planning authority our pathway is a site
where we have 30 pictures and it's
currently full so that's what we've
considered as part of this scheme
just as a follow-on to that is it
our neighboring
local authorities availability is that
material
we'd normally look in our district so
that's what we've done in this case um
to see if we've got anything in the
district that might provide an
alternative provision
council dixon
but in respect of pitches whilst we've
got some within our own
uh custody as such uh obviously when
we're looking at the gypsy traveler
assessment we do include private pitches
within that total assessment in numbers
etc and therefore if there's
availability in fundra of private
pitches which are
available but not used that is relevant
i think you what you what you should
probably take as as your reference is on
page 40 which sets out our assessment of
the gypsy uh challenge show people
assessment
that's the council's evidence base on
the availability of gypsy pitches it
shows that there is a shortfall and a
need to provide
59 pitches over the forthcoming period
and that's the basis upon which we make
our recommendation
okay anyone else have any points of
clarification before i check my coupling
they're very quick so you'll be pleasing
um uh erin it's been alluded to that
this is a retrospective planning
application um based on the pictures
i've seen i don't think it is um is it
or isn't it it is yes so in terms of the
planning statement we understand that
the family has moved on to the site and
the mobile static that they're living in
is one that's come on site which hasn't
been considered as part of the previous
application okay that's helpful thank
you and uh
i think uh it was councillor bursal said
the cotswold conservation board hasn't
been consulted should they have been or
have they been they have been consulted
we received no response
okay marvelous thank you unless anyone
else has any questions for aaron i will
move into the debate
who would like to kick us off
who am i going to pick on councillor
mills
thank you mr chairman
yeah i i
i
in terms of plenty of reason why nobody
likes a retrospective
applications as this one is but i i was
absolutely very impressed by uh council
of bursar's um statement
with so many policies there
that
i'm not sure we've contravened them
um
in that case um i i've
i mean if we have controv
contravened all these policies uh with
this site um
i'm afraid i have to go against the
office of recommendation on this one but
i'll give it give it some more thought
thank you
thank you councilman of course it is
within your gift as decision maker to
decide whether we have indeed or this
does contravene those policies
council dixon
thank you chairman i must admit i was
just looking at the uh what's described
as the gtaa the gypsian traveler
accommodation assessment
where uh again at the foot of page 20
we're advised of course uh that the
our stratford gypsy traveler
accommodation assessment recognizes that
the need can be met
through the intensification of existing
traveler sites and the provision of new
permanent traveler sites so this is
basically part of the former option i
intensification and given the size of
that site as the fact that the caravans
can be sufficiently spaced about
and
it is a replacement of a touring van
with a static
i'm in favor of the officer's
recommendation and i would propose that
we grant
thank you council dickson councillor
curtis
thank you chair um just picking up a
couple of council mills points again i
the retrospective nature of this
concerns me um and looking at policy
cs21
um 0.1 the site is not located within
the green belt
unless there are very special
circumstances or in the cotswolds area
of outstanding natural beauty
um
and
the other point that concerns me is um
let me just um
yes point three if if located in
proximity to the cotswolds a on a v the
site will have a buffer of appropriate
scale and landscaping to minimize any
adverse visual impact and we have heard
that the previous landscaping
conditions haven't yet been met so i'm
there are just a few issues around this
that do concern me thank you i reiterate
the point i made earlier on that um
and as as aaron did as well the
landscaping there is a condition in
there for landscaping and it is down to
our enforcement team to ensure that that
does come forward if they're in breach
of conditions and obviously we take the
appropriate action
council kendall
thank you chairman um like a lot of
people have said already i share the
rather human irritation with the idea of
retrospective planning applications but
that's not that's not part of our
planning grounds for making a judgment
it's completely different situation i
agree with everything council dixon said
in terms of
uh this being a suitable location for an
additional site i don't find this to be
any substantial harm i'm happy to second
his recommendation to grant
wellness thank you very much kendall
does anyone else have anything they
would like to contribute to the debate
at this stage
council fleming
i'm not sure why people are surprised
this is retrospective they usually are
um
and
the thing about this i've got direct
experience of this in bid for with two
sites um and they're always
retrospective
we have refused them in the past
inspectors always overturn them
um at the last one just a bit of brief
history that the last one that that we
refused a couple of years ago the
inspector overturned it so when they put
in another one to increase again we said
the inspector said no incremental
increases
when the planning officer came back
quite rightly and said doesn't matter
what the inspector said every new
application has to be treated separately
so there's no point in in anybody sort
of thinking that oh the inspector
you know has to overturn it or whatever
else they will get overturned because
stratfor does have a shortage of sites
um i'm going to work with councillor
pemberton who specialize in this and and
we do have a shortage of sites so from
that perspective it's always very
difficult if ever
to get these things stopped so i'm just
going to throw that so it's unlikely
i'll be supporting the officer's
recommendation but
i know it'll happen so you know it's
it's almost a kind of a
it's a buffer but it's not going to stop
it thank you understood thank you very
much i was thinking that hitler on the
head we have got a shortage um that has
been borne out in the uh officers report
which i think is very detailed and
thorough
um
and we have to meet that shortage sadly
okay so unless anyone else has anything
they want to add to the debate at this
point we will move to a vote which has
been proposed and seconded that we grant
in line with the officer recommendation
and with the additional notes on the
update sheet
so could i please have a show of hands
for those in
favor five
six six
six and those against
three and abstentions
one so committee therefore resolves to
grant application twenty one zero one
four two three ful as say in line with
the office recommendation and the two
additional notes on the update sheet
okay uh we will move now to our final
item of the evening uh which is
application reference twenty one zero
two three zero two ful that is uh pitton
hill cottages pitton hill in kington uh
our presenting officer is once again
aaron williston erin as soon as you're
ready you are free to begin thank you
very much
thank you chairman
the application site lies to the west of
kyneton outside the settlement
boundaries for this main rural centre
and within a valued landscape as
identified by the adopted neighborhood
development plan the application site is
identified by the black dot on this plan
just here
this slide shows the application site
outlined in red site comprises of a
parcel of open land to the rear of
pitton hill cottages which was recently
converted into a single dwelling
access to the site is proposed by the
existing residential access to the south
through the garden
to the sighting of the new building
the site has a neighboring property
located just here known as flaxlens and
to the south a new development for 78
dwellings is currently being built out
open fields lie to the north of the site
and to the east
planning commission is thought the
erection of a building which is proposed
for private equestrian and agricultural
storage uses as so with associated
access from the road this will be linked
to the occupants of pitton hill cottages
this slide shows an aerial image of the
area with the approximate location of
the new building outlined in red
there's open land visible on this slide
to the north and to the south you can
see the early stages of the development
being built out for the 78 dwellings it
has now progressed beyond this point and
so this slide isn't up to date in terms
of the image huntington is visible just
here
to the southeast of the site and the
land rises as you go up the road in the
northwestern direction
this slide has proposed elevations and
floor plans for the new building and the
proposed site plan see the site plan
here with the access going through the
garden to the rear to the paddock with
the proposed building in an l-shaped
platform just here
the building will be simple in design
and have a ridge height of approximately
3.2 meters and an eaves height of
approximately 2.2 meters
the building will contain two stables a
hay barn tack room and agricultural
machinery storage area
the existing access will be adjoined
onto the b486 just in this location here
and the building set just beyond the
boundary of the paddock
this slide shows a photograph taken from
the residential development from the
south looking in a northerly direction
and you see pitt and hill cottages just
to the left of this image
this photograph shows a proposed access
the left image was taken from within the
application site you can see the
property just here looking towards the
road and the photograph on the right of
this slide was from the road you can see
the gated access point just here to the
right of the dwelling
this slide has a number of photographs
taken from within the application site
so looking back from the wider paddock
towards pitton hill cottages you can see
just here with the edge of their garden
just here by the fence
and this other photographs taken looking
in more of a north direction to see the
neighboring properties just to give a
context to the site
this photograph was taken looking
towards the application site from the
edge of the paddock you see to the south
the developments and just panning around
with this final photograph you see
properties being built out to the south
of the application site there are no
updates on this application and is
recommended that planning permission be
granted subject to conditions and notes
the reasons outlined within the office
of report thank you
aaron thank you very much indeed we will
get our first speaker on this item who
is councillor david gosling councillor
gosling good evening and welcome
you've got a good idea of the drill i
think by now so you'll have three
minutes whenever you're settled and
ready to go if you press the button in
the middle to turn the microphone on and
you can start whenever you're
comfortable
good evening all at the beginning of
last year a redevelopment of an existing
building on the opposite side of pitton
hill
opposite side to this application was
seen by a planning officer as not
acceptable because it constituted
development outside the settlement
boundary and that was despite the
proposal supporting the growth of a
successful local agricultural research
and development company which would
generate increased employment
opportunities the parish council
supported that application this
application before you this evening on
the other hand is new build outside of
the built-up area boundary and it
creates no employment opportunities
the planning officer states that it
complies with policy as-10 and i hope
you've taken the opportunity to look at
this policy in detail
the office's report under the heading
principles of development cites
subclause r a supporting part of the
development
not only is the development not using
existing buildings or structures but it
is not a business business is the
overriding qualifier for subclause r
the officer then cites subclause o to
justify the remaining part of the
development and subclause o also falls
under that qualifier of business which
this development is clearly not and
confirmed by the officer as for private
use
lastly under as-10 subclause s with its
qualifier of tourism leisure is offered
to support the grant recommendation
please look closely at the wording and
ask where the local employment is
created or additional use of local
services will be generated
so this is not compliant with policy
cs24 which is about tourism leisure
which seeks to ensure that all forms of
tourism and leisure development are
designed to maximize benefits for
communities affected in terms of job
opportunities and support for local
services
under the heading of design just in
passing
in paragraph one it says access is by
the existing driveway and then that's
contradicted in paragraph four which
states a new access track will be
established not sure which is the case
um we believe that this
misinterpretation of selected clauses to
justify the recommendation to you this
evening of grant is totally unacceptable
and request that you vote against the
officer's recommendation
there is no policy within the kind
neighborhood development plan which
supports new development outside the
settlement boundary
your grounds for refusal would be
non-compliance with the counten
neighborhood development plan possibly
policies h1 and e2 and the cap district
council's core strategy policies as10
and cs24 thank you
perfect i was just about to give you a
30-second warning but there was no need
so thank you very much uh councillor
gosling remembers do we have any
questions for councillor gosling please
no
in that case council gosling thank you
very much your time and contribution
this evening and thank you very much for
sorting the discount for us
and while you're finishing up i will uh
call forward our next speaker who is mr
gary moss our agent um i do have a mr
cook as well our applicant are you both
going to be speaking
just yourself for the time being if you
want to come forward and sit and take a
seize um
mr cook i'm assuming you're here for
questions just in case so if there are
any questions obviously at that time
i'll call you forward for the time being
i think you can enjoy the comfort of
your currencies
okay
mr moss you'll have three minutes i'll
give you 30 second warning you know the
drill when you're ready
mr mustache very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for either mr mr cook
counselor curtis please
thank you thank you very much um
you
mentioned that um
closed as 10
you feel
supports this application
could you identify which particular
causes in that policy
you feel support this application
thank you
first of all i'll obviously just refer
you to the officer's principle section
of their thing which clearly uh confirms
that in their profession yes um
i was asking actually if you could
identify specifically which because you
you said that you feel
and this is supported by policy as 10 i
would like you to identify which
sections of that policy you feel
specifically support this application i
mean specifically
i would say part s which supports
small-scale leisure based uses
equine even for private use is clearly a
leisure use it has to happen in the
countryside by the nature of the
development is proposed so therefore
under policy ace-10 which is countryside
and villages it is supported i can't
remember the exact clause but if you
read at the very bottom of policy as10
as well
there's like an or covering
element to it which says
development that is appropriate
or justified through other policies i
can't remember the exact wording
hopefully you've you've probably gone to
give you the exact wording
and will need to be fully justified
offer significant benefits to the local
area
i think that's probably better thank you
very much uh yeah so even again going
back to my main point if you have an
equine use albeit private
where can it be located
i cannot see how you can locate such a
use in a built-up area boundary it just
doesn't seem practical to me in that
sense so to me the only policy of
relevance would be the countryside and
villages policy which is as10 and again
there are clearly benefits
to the local economy even from a private
equation
sorry i'm gonna i'm gonna stop you there
and i apologize that you've been cut
over twice by one of our members um you
have now answered the question um i
think we can move on uh does anyone else
have any other questions for mr moss or
our client
mr cook um council fleming please
um
looking at the at the the sketch with
the red line plan
in how many acres does this does this
development sit i mean
do the people have some some some
grazing lamb around this area
you know where
where the stable blocks going to be
built or proposed to be built is that
within their own sort of
grazing areas
for keeping the horses there
yes so the the application site is um
although constrained to the red line the
actual paddock field um
is in the ownership of the applicant as
well so they do have immediate land
there's no requirement for
and looking at again looking at
the the layout map
um
if it sits in open countryside if it's
only just if it's less than three meters
tall can anybody else see it from the
back garden is it going to be
detrimental is it going to cause harm in
what people can see
in i think the photographs and as the
case office has presented um i mean
you will see it there are
you know uh
views of the building
um
but in terms of its location um
you know and size and scale it's not
going to be a
prominent feature in the landscape and
again because of its nature equine
agricultural use it will be an
appropriate building in such a location
it's not like a a residential building
which would look perhaps
out of character okay thank you thank
you okay any further questions for
either mr moss or mr cook
no in that case thank you very much for
your contribution and time this evening
okay uh we have no other registered
speakers on this item so we'll move two
points of clarification to our officers
does anyone have any points of
clarification for aaron please
no
counsel adam
um just with regards to the concern
just
regards to the concerns of the parish
council um and as 10 about
private use versus business use
um
i'd
just some clarification more than
anything really i don't know anything
more specific
so in terms of this case we've looked at
all the policies in as10 and the ndp as
well and in terms of the principle um
it's part
talks about a question in as10 but it's
part s where it's small-scale leisure in
this case we feel it meets that part and
cs24 and so from an officer's point of
view we feel it meets the provisions of
as10 and the relevant ndp policies in
terms of the principle for private youth
okay any other questions at this point
and otherwise we'll move into debate who
would like to kick us off councillor
jennings please
just an excuse to get that off
right um
i understand uh
so it's interesting listening to that
and the the minor benefits to the local
economy or my wife has horses it's not
minor it costs her a fortune what it
costs across us unfortunately so
it certainly contributes a lot to the
local economy but i'm happy that this
that this satisfies a as-10 clause s um
it's for it's for leisure based i again
i don't see how you can set up a stable
block um
in the middle of a built up area
boundary
i
i don't have an issue with this at all
i don't see any material planning
reasons to go against the officer's
recommendation for grant and i'd like to
propose that
council james thank you very much
council kendall
thank you chairman um yeah i think
you've said well i was good oh what i
was thinking too i certainly understand
the parish council's frustration
especially comparing um one application
with another i can understand how
sometimes you it's difficult to see the
difference between those and i can so i
understand the frustration there but i
failed to see any demonstrable harm from
this i think the applicant's agent said
it quite well where else are you going
to put this sort of a facility and yes i
think there will be benefit to the
community so i'm happy to second
proposal
thank you very much does anyone else
like to contribute towards the debate at
this point
no okay in that case we have a proposal
it has been seconded to granting the
officer's recommendation could i please
have a show of hands for those in favor
please
that is unanimous okay so committee
therefore resolves to grant application
twenty one zero two three zero two ful
uh pitton hill costas button hill in
kington um i don't believe we have any
other business or any urgent business
no in that case um it reminds me to
thank you all for your contributions
this evening your time and i will close
the meeting there thank you very much